le dôme zelensky dans le port de churn
de remorques sur la mer noire le
président ukrainien est allé superviser
un premier chargement de céréales à sur
un navire turc après des mois d'impasse
les exportations de blé et de maïs
doivent reprendre écoutez
nous sommes entièrement préparé nous
avons envoyé tous les signaux à nos
partenaires l'onu et la turquie est
notre arme et garantit la situation
sécuritaire
le ministre des infrastructures et en
contact direct avec la partie turque et
l'onu nous attendons un signal de leur
part pour pouvoir commencer manche d'un
brunch au nahd bonjour à vous de l'hiver
kragbé spécial de france 24 à odessa
gulliver à ce qu'on en sait un petit peu
plus sur cette opération à ce qu'un
premier navire a donc pu s'élancer ou
pas encore
non pour le moment aucun navire n'a
quitté l'un des trois ports concernés
par cet accord il y à un navire dans le
port de tarnos mort sq qui a bougé d'un
amarrage un autre amar âgé plus près de
la mer mais n'a pas n'est pas encore
sorti du port les ukrainiens d'ist
attendre un signal de la turquie et de
l'onu mais la turquie et l'onu sont des
intermédiaires en réalité dans cette
histoire en réalité c'est un signal des
russes qu'ils disent attendre que les
russes peuvent vraiment garantir la
sécurité du passage de ces navires mais
la route qu'ils doivent suivre a été
publié aussi le système c'est un navire
ukrainien tweddle qui doit précéder tout
navire commercial transportant des
grains il devrait y avoir aussi de
vaisseaux militaires turcs pour assurer
la sécurité et le cargo la cargaison
doit être acheminée inverse le port
roumain dessous l'ina à l'embouchure du
danube et là au large de souligner à il
y aura des inspections avant de procéder
encore vers la turquie mais je dois vous
dire que tous les interlocuteurs
ukrainien à qui j'ai pu parler ces
derniers jours que ce soit agriculteur
militaire ou experts sont encore assez
sceptique quant à la possibilité que cet
accord marchera ils disent tous que
l'ukraine espère sincèrement que
l'accord va pouvoir assurer le départ de
ses grands mais que le niveau de
confiance en la russie est extrêmement
bas surtout bien sûr après que la russie
a tiré des missiles sur le port d'odessa
seulement au lendemain de la signature
de l'accord voilà ce qu'on peut dire
pour l'heure donc sur la tente de la
reprise de ses exportations de céréales
qui selon ce que vous voulez d'expliquer
gulliver n'est pas encore acté